first Hollywood party I ever went to was
at Val Kilmer's house randomly really so
I was like Val Kilmer's house I'm like I
gotta be a funny dancer so I just I do
like a go down to try to be funny
whatever and uh rip my pants wide open
I'm wearing a red thong so it kind of
just looks like I have a bloody ass I
just beelined into a Val Kilmer's closet
and took a shirt and just wrapped it
around my waist you didn't go home no I
didn't have a car I was with like a
group of people and I put it on my waist
and it was like a very obviously like
like shirt you would notice and then he
starts talking to me and I'm wearing his
shirt around my waist and I'm like is he
gonna notice that I took one of his
shirt it just and it never did and then
I sold it at Buffalo Exchange I made
like forty dollars wow but I know money
I used to sell people's clothes